de quoi souhaitiez où on parlait
de ma patiente bonjour je sais que vous
êtes anxieuse je veux juste qu'on
discute
je vois une chose que je suis la seule à
foix
une chose qui me sourit
[Musique]
hier une passion que vous suiviez est
morte de façon violente sous vos yeux
j'ai besoin de trouver une explication
[Musique]
tu vas mourir tu vas mourir
j'ai relevé pas à faire impliquant dix
neuf victimes directement reliées entre
elles
[Musique]
tu as parlé que de 19 victimes
pourquoi tous ceux qui l'ont vue sont
morts et pas vous
cela fut aussi
vous
[Applaudissements]
combien de temps entre la mort de chaque
victime
aucune n'a survécu au delà d'une semaine
aujourd'hui c'est mon quatrième jour je
peux plus fuir comme ça
il faut que je l'affronté et qu'est ce
que ça vous fait
j'ai tellement peur qu'il se passe
quelque chose de terrible
[Applaudissements]